hello everyone and welcome to the 2018
World Championship match between Magnus
cross and Fabiana Caruana
for those of you who are perhaps new to
this channel or perhaps new to this
match this is game number nine as we
already mentioned the first eight games
have ended in a draw so the result so
far is four to four but you know all
these drawers it's not unheard of like
if you go really back to to a match
between Alaska and selectra out of the
out of the first ten games that were
played only two were decisive if you go
back to 1978 to when a Karpov played
Korchnoi
out of the first ten games only one was
decisive in the course and corrected
match in 2016
out of the 12 games only two were
decisive so it's I don't know it's not
really that the engines are creating all
of these draws it's just that it's a
world championship match obviously the
two people competing are almost equally
strong you know it's hard to say we you
have to go now
through through the regulations as they
are twelve games of classical chance
they then go into Rapids then go into
bliss then into Armageddon and whatnot
but it's not really nothing new so it's
very interesting to see what happens in
game nine as Carson has the white pieces
for the for the fifth time and he
prepared something that was not yet
played in this match before we check out
the actual game now we do have a couple
of nice photos by Nikki Riga and for
those of you who perhaps do not follow
chess in the media so much or on social
networks here we have a very nice photo
of another diagonal handshake and as you
can see there is not a lot of eye
contact going on either
Carlson arrives at the scene and as you
can see he has an eye patch it's not
really an eye patch but uh but a little
plaster over the eye here we have a a
nicer photo also called improvements of
Nikki Riga if you're still not following
her I will put a couple of links to her
social media in the description below
you can check out some of her more work
for more excellent photos but today you
can see and his rest day Carson had an
accident he he was playing football and
he well he did not his teammate but a
player from the opposing team they
collided with heads the the player on
the opposing team was a reporter for
four vgtv for Norwegian television and
he also has an injury such as this one
and it's you know also an interesting
thing to discuss whether it's wise to
play such aggressive sport you know on
your rest days it can seriously
interfere with the match but Carson
thinks it's okay and you know he arrives
at the game wearing this well not an
eyepatch and also here we have a very
nice close-up of Fabiano as you can see
he is not at all injured very focused
and very prepared for the game I didn't
really Center it all that great and
there you go alright now that we've
check out the photo Center we've
discussed a little bit before this game
let's see how game 9 went Carson wood
white pieces opens with c4 and we've
already seen this it's we will see the
same variation that was played in Game
four of the 2018 custom versus car won a
match but with a slightly different
preparation from Carlson and you will
see in this game Carson really really
came prepared
so Knight to c3 we have the English
opening on the board Knight to f6 Knight
f3 knight c6 the four Knights variation
of the English g3 and now D file the
exact same line that was played in Game
four we have pawn captures Knight
captures and now Bishop to G - we have
Bishop to c5 and now comes castles Bobby
castles like in game four we have d3
rook to e8 and here we already discussed
this during our showing of Game four
here Bishop to d2 was played by Carlsen
but also Bishop d2 is a move of Wesley
so already played against Caruana in
2018 in the grand chest towards a blitz
tournament in Paris but here Colson
prepares
Bishop to g5 and ok Caruana did come
prepared for this move but he also
pretty much instantly blissed-out Knight
captures on c3 we have B captures on c3
just the show you can't
trade queens here because you will just
be down a piece after Bishop captures
Knight captures you will get the special
part of the way and then after Knight
captures on me too if you just quickly
count the pieces you can see that black
has four pieces and that white has will
use this nice blue color sorry about
that
actually three minor pieces so basically
just losing the piece but after knife
captures on c3b captures on c3 and now
comes f6 simply kicking the bishop back
here call someplace in the shop to see
one and Caruana mentioned in the press
conference after the game that he didn't
know that the bishop see that the c1
doesn't come as a surprise to him of
course he did not expect bishop to d2 as
you want to leave this square open for
the night the night might be interested
in a maneuvers such as 92 night b3 going
after the bishop and then a4 a5 and he
replied the bishop to e6 relatively
quickly but here Carlsen again blitzed
out this Bishop to b2 move and this is
the first time in the game that Caruana
started I think and it took him some
nine minutes to figure out what's going
on here he said that he might have
already encountered this move but that
he just couldn't you know I recollect
his memories about seeing it okay push
it back to b6 you don't want to play
this move at some point either way it's
just undefended on c5 being making it a
target theater the knight can attack it
or you the B file is also half open so
at some point you will be able to
perhaps attack the B file using your
rook but here immediately Bishop to b6
and okay we have d4 by Carlson and again
Khurana I had to spend some time here to
figure out what the best reply is if you
go into an exchange here it doesn't
really change all that much but after
I've captures an Bishop to d5 a very
important move that you definitely want
to include the counter White's strong
bishop how it will simply go III and the
white position will be excellent the
bishop will be kind of silly here
attacking this very strong d4 pawn you
will then have to figure out a play how
to move your night somewhere push c5 to
at least try and attack with white
center but here as a Giri so
so nicely put it you don't want to trade
in the center as basically you don't
want to release the tension in the
center without gaining anything it's one
of the general principles in chess but
is Geary mentions you don't want to
release the tension in the center as
it's a sign of weakness but as a sign of
weakness of character so Caruana
plays Bishop to d5 immediately without
you know doing anything about this
central tension here Queen to c2 by
Carlson also you do you do have to you
don't have to play something of course
if you try something like e for here
instead after Queen to c2 it's it's a
it's definitely a move but white will
simply move the knight 92 which it
probably want to go it there anywhere or
night to h4 and then you you're not
gonna be able to do any damage in the
center and now this Bishop on b6 will
really look ugly so instead we have a
capture Sun before finally by car wanna
see capture Sun before and now comes a
Bishop to e4 if you go into an exchange
immediately for example Bishop captures
on f3 then you get a bunch of captures
on f3 Knight captures on d4 rush of
characters and now Queen captures on d4
bushel capture some b7 and now after the
rook moves locate the b8 you will be
able to bring the bishop back and now
you will at some point want to play King
g2 most likely get rid of the queen with
III and Gabriel also mentioned the dis
that he would then go h4 h5 and now the
f6 pawn will be really be a problem
as you will simply try to create more
weaknesses and that it will be very hard
for black to do anything so rush up to
d4 cause and moves the Queen we have
Queen to b3 check attacking the king
if King to h8 then simply e3 will be
fine for white but Caruana goes back
Bishop to d3 and now as Lauren strengths
so conveniently tease the giri in the
livestream it you know it's a possible
that white will go back Queen c2 and
then we will have a repetition by
perpetual check here but should be for
Queen b3 Bishop to d5 more players will
agree to a draw
but of course it would be a terrible
shame if ifs anything like this happened
so after Bishop to d5 cross and solid of
course he cannot go back to c2 he went
Queen to d1 and as Kerwin also mentioned
in the press conference he said that
most likely after the screen to d1 move
even Carson was now not swimming in the
you know safe waters of preparation
anymore so okay Bishop captures on f3
and this move really came as a surprise
to a lot of people as it's a it's a very
committal move which will simply leave
black worse for the rest of the game and
basically what everyone said that Carson
will get to the exact position that he
really wants to play where he will have
a slight edge where and there really
won't be any weaknesses in his position
so he can just play it long play it out
for as long as he wants so here you
could capture it immediately with Bishop
captures on f3 which would pretty much
bring us to the same idea that happened
in the game first cross and play the
Queen to b3 check now of course you can
to block with the bishop because the
bishop the other bishop will simply
capture it if you block the number of
captures and then white can't even
consider doubling black's pawn structure
here so we have Queen b3 check Caruana
move the King King to h8 and now comes
the bishop captures on f3 Knight
captures on d4 with Bishop captures
Queen captures of course not Bishop
captures if you capture with the bishop
and then rook a to d1 will simply trap
it you don't have time to get rid of it
as the Queen is on the 8th III is coming
and you will simply lose a piece here so
after Bishop captures on d4 we have
Queen captures on d4 and now comes a e3
attacking the Queen here and now comes
the Queen to e5
Queen to e5 the most likely the best
square for the Queen if you go Queen to
c5 then white has a lot more options for
example Bishop captures on b7 it's a
move that would be played in pretty much
every line regardless of where the black
Queen goes but here after rook to b8 you
will have perhaps an idea of going
something like Queen to a4 now of course
you cannot capture the bishop because
Queen captures rook is a possibility and
then black will have to waste one more
move
kick the Queen away but then even Queen
to c6 is a possibility and now your
queen isn't really all that impressive
here on a5 but basically by playing
Queen to e5 it's the best central square
for the Queen always you know if not
proven otherwise a central square is the
best square for the Queen also the Queen
keeps an eye on this rook so there won't
be any funny business going on on the
Queen side but should capture some b7
has planned and now rook a to d8 there's
no point in going look it rook here even
if you are saying that okay if the
bishop moves my rook will be x-raying
the Queen
but after Bishop g2 there's really no
way to take advantage of this there's no
good discovery on the Queen you can't
even capture an e3 well the Queen will
simply capture the bishop and you will
lose a bishop here so after Bishop
captures on b7 locate the d8 immediately
Caruana introduces this rook now into
into the game via the central file rook
a to d1 countering the rook and now
Queen back to e7 by Caruana
keeping an eye on this rook if an
exchange happens then the other row can
come there as well and also if if Carson
starts pushing the H pawn which is
definitely an idea at some point Coulson
wants to play the ship to f3 and starts
pushing the pawn Caruana
wants to play f5 and have this Queen
controlling the h4 square which we will
see in the game the cousin does go h4
and here in an interview cousin Carlsen
called this decision this h4 move a
ridiculous idea and he thought that he
he most likely had better ideas like
Bishop to c6 or maybe simply improving
with King to g2 either just making
improving the position before making
such a committal move with h4
because at some point if the H file even
opens up you don't want to bring your
rook over to h1 so it would definitely
help to have a king and g2 but he
immediately started with h4 and here
after some consideration Caruana
plays g6 he if you go into exchanges
immediately with rook captures and
captures Ruby d8 and you go into even
more exchanges than Queen to f7 will be
and
extremely troublesome move you can't
really push the Queen away if you attack
it the Queen will go to d7 and now the
Queen and Bishop will be very strong the
bishop is coming to d5 to attack the
Queen and now after the Queen moves
Bishop will still come to d5 and after
g60 will either even be able to push h5
and it will be a very unpleasant
position for black
for example c5 and now even h6 possible
where of course you will never be able
to capture it because you will simply
get checkmated after Queen Queen e8
check but even better simply commercial
to e4 it would a double attack here and
then it will be like even if even if you
push f5 then this comes with the threat
of mate white is definitely making some
progress but karana doesn't go into
anything like that after h4 he pushes g6
and here Carlson here cousin decided to
push h5 which is an extremely committal
move but it's not not to be unexpected
if he prepared it with something like
Queen to c4 or any other move karana
would most likely simply play h5 prepare
f5 and then this this structure would be
unbreakable
for white or if he tried something else
if you tried here an idea like King g2
to perhaps create some room for this
rook to come use the the soon-to-be open
H file then we could see at King g7 h5
and now Rock captor son d1 rook captures
Ruby d8 and now even if you try to take
advantage of the H file now rook to d2
comes as a bit of a problem because now
your F pawn is pinned ideas like Queen
captures or Bishop captures on e3 become
possible and again it's it's a very
unpleasant position for for even white
so you can't really allow such things in
a World Chess Championship match now if
after g6 curls and pushes h5 immediately
and here your instincts are telling you
to not capture on h5 but it's actually
the best move here and karana does play
it he plays G captures on h5 and now now
you have problems Corona has plans of
playing f5 and h4 he wants to open up
the G file use the Geo
for his rooks and attack call since King
as well so although white is still
slightly better as the dark square
Bishop on b6 is well one of the most
useless pieces ever unless at some point
this mushroom returns to f3 then perhaps
ideas like Bishop capture some III will
be possible but that's a different story
here across some place Queen to c4 he
doesn't want to allow this pawn to come
to h4 we have f5 now the queen is also
guarding h4 one of the reasons core
wanna played this Queen back to e7 a few
moves back and here again if he goes
into something like King g2 then then h4
is coming and after rook to h1 you can
either even play H capture some g3 and
the semi-open H file will not do all
that much for you after Queen c3 Czech
Queen g7 blocking you can even capture
here and after king capture son g3
captures captures will be simply a pawn
down for white and with nothing to show
for it ok you will claim some activity
with rook to d7 perhaps but nothing
nothing serious
so after f5 we have brush up to f3 by
Carlsen and now comes h4 karana is
definitely putting up a very active
defense and even though at this point
Caruana was I believe more than an hour
down on the clock still his position
seems to be improving step by step
perhaps by course and pushing that h4 h5
too soon but it's I mean it's it's hard
to say Luke chapter Sunday it was played
rocked after sandy 8 and now G captures
on h4 simply capturing that pawn and
here after this we have rook to g8 check
or you could do something like Queen
captures on h4 instead instead of G
captures but then you go into a queen
trade and after Queen captures G
captures even f4 is sufficient for 4 for
a draw as the bishops are of opposite
color after you capture you can go rook
here you are definitely gonna win back
the pawn either the f1 or the h1 so
after rakia rope captures and you will
not even be able to move the bishop
because of this very nice pressure
against the f2 points so black will even
better here so like we said G captures
on h4 was played and now comes rock to
GA check King to h1 by Carson and now
Queen to f6 here across someone for
Queen to f4 and now comes Bishop to c5
wanting to bring that Bishop over to d6
to dislodge the White Queen and also
perhaps create some very nice attacking
chances himself we have looked at g1
Carlsen now has the exchange rooks row
capture skin captures and now comes
Bishop to d6 you don't have time for
something like Queen to a1 check this
would be very reckless King g2 and
capturing a pawn as Queen v5 check King
moves and of course you don't even
capture the bishop but Queen and Bishop
b5 check picks up the Queen from a - so
of course not definitely not the time to
be picking up pawns will push up to d6
and now comes Queen to a4 we have f4 and
now comes Queen captures on a7 also
perhaps you could push efore and you
know yes you have created a passed pawn
which will most likely never be pushed
but then even Queen captures on h4 as
possible
and after something like Queen to d4
check King moves Queen captures on a7
Queen g5 check comes and now it will be
a force to draw after Queen to be 5
because you have to go back to g1
there's no way for you to come to all
the way here because now you get the
Bishop to b4 check and you're going to
get made at Queen d3 check King moves
and now it's a simply a very easy a
check mating pattern
so after f4 we have the immediate Queen
captures on a 7 by Carlsen we have F
captures on III and Queen captures back
on a on e3 so here Carlsen his up
opponent but not for long it seems a
quite dangerous for Caruana to actually
capture this point because of some Queen
d8 checks but he calculates precisely
and there are in fact no dangers here
you know unfortunately for Coulson
he captures on h4 and now comes a for
Carlsen starts pushing his passport
but even if like we said he did
something like wind eh check you can
always simply move the King King g7
Queen d7 and now you can
even block with the Queen but you can
also just play the King back to h8 and
claim that black white still has nothing
so Carson plays a four and it's like we
already mentioned this is more 37 car
one is low on time he still has to make
three more moves to reach time control
although he could capture the pawn he
does not capture this pawn because if
you if to capture this pawn if you play
Queen captures then you have to
calculate okay now you do protect this
square but then you allow Queen c3 check
and then you have to go into what
happens if King g8 and then I get bunch
of d5 check King goes here Queen to h8
check King g7 Queen captures on h7 and
then where do I go am i safe what of
course you can escape going back but you
know it's it's you know calculation
that's not needed if you're very long
time but you're just show there are even
dangerous if you giving checkmate it so
are you can go here and then after
something like Queenie six check King
moves or you can go here and then lose
the Queen after this but most likely
after spawning such such variations
check and here now the pawn and Bishop
create a very nice wall against the
black king so now you are definitely
getting checkmated Bishop f3 check King
moves and now after Queen check this
will be checkmate so after a four
Caruana doesn't want to needlessly
calculate moves
so simply Queen back to f6 controlling
this very important diagonal so there
are no tricky moves here by Carlsen rush
up to d1 Queen to e5 offering a queen
trade and there's there's really nothing
better to do you can only know they get
become worse if you allow Queen to HT to
check across and decides to exchange
Queen's Queen captures Bishop captures
and now a five-course and makes move 40
this is time control and with the g7
Caruana also makes move 40 so two points
each bishops of opposite color they did
play it out for a little bit a six but
now Quran of course
controls the dark square diagonal we
have Kim G to King to f6 and now Bishop
and now F for controlling the King here
Bishop to b6 but
doesn't it's you know it's not a problem
if you run into this check or anything
you just simply pick up this point for
this point which is perfectly fine so
after a for Bishop to b6 we have king of
three h6 now and now came to e4
we have bishop goes back we have Bishop
to g4 and now Bishop to g1 simply
controlling this very important g1 a
seven diagonal King defy Bush back to b6
we have king c6 Bishop goes back King b7
or you can capture on c7 but it really
doesn't it doesn't make a difference
here black and black can draw in in
various ways he can simply capture here
with check and then after you move back
still control this very important
diagonal you can even give up the bishop
here and of course you no longer have
any points so you cannot win the game or
even in a funny way you can give up this
point and it will be over just as well
Bishop captures now comes came to a5 you
will pick up this pawn as it's on a dark
square and after you pick it up again
you will have this King against the King
and Bishop which is of course a draw by
insufficient material so after Bishop to
e3 King Tubby 7 was played and now we
have Bishop back to b6
Bishop h3 Carson is controlling f5 and
this pawn is controlling he 5 and g5
so there is a wall that the black king
can never cross and Carson was hoping
that at some point perhaps h5 would be
played and then he could maybe somehow
outmaneuver the black king well
obviously not this way but maybe maybe
this way and then you use the bishop to
push the black king away but such things
are highly highly improbable bunch of to
e3 attacking the pawn but now simply
King moves back Russia back to b6 of
course you don't want to allow something
like Bishop captures and an a7 then of
course you can no longer prevent the
cleaning of this pawn with anything
so after king c6 will have Bushra back
to b6 not really much of a task corona
can simply just keep pushing the bishop
back and forth King de 5 Bishop 287 King
before
Bishop to b6 Bishop to f1 King e6 Bishop
to c4 check King moves back Bishop to d3
King e6 and it was in this position that
the players agreed to a draw this is
more 56 so another draw well used by
Crossan although it simply was not yet
enough I'm very interested that what do
you think because it's it's a very well
known fact that Caruana trains a lot of
yoga so perhaps it really helps him with
his nerves during such a huge event like
the World Chess Championship match this
is already game 9 where you know you're
constantly playing and everything in the
chess world the entire chest world is
basically watching your game so I don't
know seems like yoga and chess could
really go well together and also they
asked Caruana and after the game in the
press conference is he also of a similar
mind that if three more games are drawn
that cousin has a cousin is the huge
favorite in in the tiebreaks but corwin
actually said that he does not agree
with everyone there that he he considers
his chances you know not not to be such
poor that everyone as everyone describes
them so yeah basically that's game 9 I
do hope you enjoyed it really a lot of
fireworks possible that that never
happened I would like to thank lemon
Mauro Alberto NSC and Max come in Tony
more what guitar and Brentford pillock
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciated as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here I think all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and if you have any
interesting content you would like to
suggest always use hashtag suggestion
and when I have the time I will always
check out your suggestions thank you all
and I will see you soon